joining us here on the rich eisen show
here in hour number two in studio one of
my favorite humans on the planet and
everybody needs to get this book that
i'm holding in my hand it is called
unbreakable how i turn my depression and
anxiety into motivation and you can too
truly one of the more inspirational
people i've ever met he is none other
than jay glazer good to see you
appreciate it brother hey so hold that
up yes sir
so i think you can see also um and my
voice is a little shot
but then wearing the same shirt here the
same strand shirt the msx line okay as
there
which just shows you that this is pretty
much the only shirt i ever wear yeah
i'm good with it you don't want jeffy
you are i can attest you are still an
evolved person
you have evolved
but you've got your look and it works
for you
am i a sit back guy or am i are you are
you fleeing forward are you a lean
forward guy i think i'm a lean forward
okay you're a lean forward guy
he's a lean forward guy he's not a
setback guy god bless you good to see
you yeah tj you got that thing covered
very good there we go very good uh
congratulations on that thank you
brother appreciate it i mean you poured
you poured everything into this book
i did and you know you know a lot of the
work that i do with with our vets and
our players with mvp and i've been
really open to that
closed circle
right i'm vulnerable look look
man being involved in mixed martial arts
for a long time like no one's
questioning my manhood so i could cry on
the drop of a dime and
what we say in those circles man we we
really help each other
and this is an opportunity for me to
help a lot more people than just our
close circle and use my own struggles
and you know it's so
it's so funny man i am always so proud
of my scars from fighting so i'm always
willing to tell people yeah my back's
messed up because you know randy couture
and chuck liddell are beating the crap
out of me and so i got i've ruptured l4
l5 uh four times in l1 l2 twice and
herniated c2345 and broke that ankle
twice and woke up during surgery there
broke this seven times for man look you
can see i get excited well now it's time
we start bragging about our mental scars
as much as our physical scars that's
what we need to do so without
my gray i call it my depression anxiety
i i've realized i actually wouldn't be
where i am right now like it's motivated
me to get where i am and and to do all
these these great things when did you
first realize
that you could use it as motivation as
opposed to letting it drag you
under
jay so
well first of all it's
um
it's my earliest childhood memory like i
don't know what it's like to not live in
the gray
seriously yeah okay so what what's your
how when do you i don't know if it's you
know what when did you start living in
gray or realizing i just don't know
another thing and
man it's really hard when you live when
you have my level of
depression anxiety and that's why
my darkness is able to help i think lead
others so like i've got to go through it
to be able to talk about it
and you know this book is for people
like me but people like
for everybody we just went through a
pandemic everybody's going through some
sort of gray right and social media
sucks so you know we all think our
our livestock because we're comparing
ourselves to everybody else filtered
fraction of a second and we feel left
out so it's for for everybody but
um
man i don't know what it's like to wake
up in the blue like i just
even today right yeah so every single
day
i wake up and there's a lot of things i
got to do to get myself convinced the
sky's not falling the world doesn't hate
me everyone's not out to get me things
aren't crashing because when you have my
level of depression anxiety you don't
feel worthy of being loved
you know and
you kind of can't look at yourself the
way everybody else sees you
so you see all that so as a result of me
not
really understanding how to love myself
from the inside out
i've had to go out and do all these big
things
to try and get a bunch of love from the
outside in
and i'm trying to get it where i could
piece together
enough of that and enough blue where um
maybe we meet in the middle and
you know and i could start feeling
love from the inside out like that's i'm
a work in progress i'm still going and
this book for me
um
it's a healing journey for me also i'm
i'm trying to help everybody else out
but at the same time man i still need
the help
how many uh have you come across in the
nfl who have similar
issues jay you can't be in the nfl not
be crazy like you gotta
that's one way
it's true though but also anybody who's
great you can't be great not be crazy
like your work ethic and that's what we
tell people
in mvp are charity all the time for guys
when they finish up playing in the nfl
like you play in the nfl that's not who
we are
right what's behind your rib cage right
that got you to beat out millions and
millions and millions to play on that
level that's who you are and that's a
level of crazy to to put that kind of
work in and to say hey i'm gonna put a
football helmet on every day and go bang
my buddy and aaron donald like you're
off you know for me
i'm great in chaos i think these players
are great and cast i suck and calm so
when man i was calm
i want my good i would take three steps
up in the cage with chuck liddell and
hey come kick me in the face like hey
give me more cte like that's off i'm off
right and um
what i think the problem in the nfl
is
they
don't talk about it enough they aren't
you know it's
um it's it's not being used as a badge
of honor like it should be
and that's what i'm trying to get
everybody to shift like i'll tell you
this every single person i've had the
conversation with the world of fighting
the world of football whatever it is
um i only started coming forward with
this in these terms if you will within
the last two years
it's gotten me closer to every single
one of them
so
anybody who's afraid at home
for the shame
i'm
guaranteeing you
that it will get you closer with someone
when you could share and
you never know when you share
who's going to come back say oh my god
you
me too and i've i've had an awful lot of
that um
people look i hide it great
i'm always laughing big personalities
like i'm going through life relentless
relentlessly um so i've hit it all these
years and
i didn't hide my crazy but i always hit
my pain who told you these stories for
your book here jay glaser that uh you
can that um
that where
people were like yeah me too and oh my
god you're they they allowed you to tell
or wanted you to tell or anything like
that so the the wildest thing um again i
agree to write the book people have been
trying to get me to write a football
book for years i'm like
uh i'm not looking over my shoulder for
the rest of my life with the secrets
that i know right but a mental health
book a book where i could be a service
absolutely i'm in
so
you know the way i describe my gray i
call it living in the gray depression
anxiety
um
man i really pulled my skin back and
actually
i've actually never said this anywhere
else i'll tell you okay um
i like saying but um
i stop going to treatment my treatment
is all the time
i stopped going
while i was doing the book
so i could really
feel it to describe it to people
and still pulling myself out of that
really yeah it's taken me
a year
but i wanted to uh
and you see again the pain yeah um
i wanted to really
um
i wanted to be fully of service to
people so i wanted to sacrifice and make
sure man i really got people to
understand what
your son's going through your daughter
or your wife or her husband i got a
message from a grandmother
yesterday
that
finally she has the words to have a
conversation with her family
she's never known how to say it how to
describe it so we talk about mental
health
but no one describes it so i'm able to
describe it here and describe it in
really really stark terms
but
the conversation
uh in the book you refer to when i pull
my skin back and i really tell people it
was it was a year ago this week i was
down in cabo with andrew whitworth who
like whit goes through it like wit
people don't realize it he's same like
me like he uses his darkness to go do
great things and be the walter payton
man of the year which
he's beyond that he's the man of the
freaking century um the left tackle of
the ranch around the captain of the rams
right and
you know whit
and i were with mcveigh down in cabo
um actually went down there um
this was the stanford stanford
weekend when i tell you stafford it was
not planned he literally happened to
check in a hotel
the next day and mcveigh was supposed to
leave
he only stayed because
like woodworth had a room for me i was
actually i was going through some stuff
and would say okay bro what are you
doing like we got a room for you here in
uh in cabo why don't you come down i'm
like now he's like why would you not
like don't just sit there and isolate
right so i was like
yeah okay so got a plane went down to
cabo mcveigh set off he's going to stay
then i'm going to stay and then stafford
happened to check in our hotel the next
day and now they're checking into the
nfc championship game you know it's time
for alex to say i said it started in the
hot tub which we did
um and then that's when those two dudes
fell in love with each other and man
they made it happen right there right
but
the night before stafford got there
we're at dinner and mcveigh's like man
so and whit and i are kind of talking
about the darkness
and they're like man we're proud of you
for writing this book and shawn goes hey
so
to fully describe this like you just
wake up
like sad every day i said yeah
he says why i'm like
because i have depression [ __ ] he's
like no thanks great he's like
and then he goes no i want to i want to
know like t and then
i said man think i'm much better of a
coach you could be if you could really
really understand this
and he's like yeah like how many of the
guys in the locker room you think have
it
and whit goes
all of us he's like you too and he's
like yeah what do you think gets me to
like go and smash my body every day for
40 years so it's challenging they didn't
know that whitworth you know
right right and especially from your
coach and everybody that so people are
so afraid in the league like man if i
show this
vulnerability right it's going to be
weak and they may cut me that's the fear
they're not going to cut you okay
they're going to put their arms around
you they're going to help you they're
going to love you up look what happened
with lane johnson this year
calvin ridley right
their arms around but all the people who
reach out they will help you and they'll
get you closer there's another player
and teams are now starting to call me
about it saying hey
can you help us can you help us how do
we talk to this person or right you know
give us some some insight hey man just
tell him you you got you know
his version of what's happening that's
not the truth put your arms around them
let them know that because we a lot of
us think the world's against us when
it's not and as a result when you think
the world's against you you push the
world away from you
right
so when you push the world away from you
it's self-fulfilled prophecy then oh see
that the world is against me but you're
the one doing the pushing
so
for this book when i recount the story
or when i describe to people what the
gray what it's like living in the gray
it's the conversation with sean that
went on for for a while and i said sean
think about
how much better of a coach you could be
again and he said well how many of our
players have it and i said that's not
the question you need to ask yourself
the question is how many of our how many
are your secretaries how many of your
scouts how many your assistant coaches
how many people in your building how
many people you just don't know and man
he was is
it was incredible to see kashan
his life's amazing like
if i could put
someone's life in a pill and make an
antidepressant it would be sean mcvay
and
like the worst thing that ever happened
to him is he didn't win the super bowl
second year coaching as a young youngest
coach in a fellowship and his parents
look like they're like
the people in the picture frames when
you buy pictures you know picture trends
at target
so
he got it man he got it and this year
he's called a bunch in i'm so glad we
have that talk because it's allowed me
to be more vulnerable with my team and a
lot of times do the leaders
they don't know they could be vulnerable
because they got to think oh i got to be
for everybody else right so
they lead everybody else but man who
takes care of the leaders
unbreakable how i turned my depression
and anxiety into motivation and you can
too
with jay glazer and um on the back you
got guy fieri who is just the fiery
piano yeti part of me guy fieri um
hey tj demi lovato wrote uh a um
a blurb as well in the back you know
yeah he knows demi very well
um tomlin randy couture on the back and
you could have gotten anybody you wanted
brother
so sean payton has a great quote in the
book
in that depression chapter because i did
i mean i i use a lot of my and it's not
just this book isn't just about the gray
it's
overcoming for business and how i got to
where i am in my career and this
unbreakable mindset i use for business
for training for fighting and football
and there's a practical jokes chapter
because
i use laughter a lot and there's pillars
to get through it and the practical joke
chapter is
um i that that is
how long is my muse you'll see what i've
done in my life
and um that's fantastic but sean payton
had a line of that it said
hurt people hurt people
think of that
right people are hurting heard people
hurt people i was like wow so
i uh i put that in the book so spoiler
no i mean there's so many stories in
here that you've you've barely even
scratched the surface here as part of
you know your career and how you got to
where you are and if there's three items
three messages
uh that you want people to get out of
this
go forward there's three pillars there
too i said to get through the gray it's
a prescript prescriptive book for
anybody at home right and
number one is
find your team that's what mvp does
right find your team right and my team
could be anywhere from my fox nfl sunday
crew um you know obviously my fight team
god's my team like this i have team
um your friends are your team your
family is your team there's different
teams
number two be of service so there's i
list several ways in the book
even when i was broken and broke you
know what now's making 9 700 bucks a
year for the first 10 years of my career
and try to outwork the world so i
couldn't get another job
um
like part-time job to pay the bills i
had to
work 80-90 hours a week to try and beat
everybody else there right
you know covering the nfl and the giants
and then the league but even then i
found ways to be of service
right and there's several different way
like i still do it to this day i'll go
to like the 99 cent store and buy
toothbrush toothpaste handy wipes
deodorant gloves
pen paper socks and hand them out to
homeless that cost eight bucks right so
there's ways to be of service
being of service it will lift your soul
and the third one is laughter
and i laugh an awful lot you guys see me
on fox laughing yes a lot of it is yeah
because i want to entertain you at home
but a lot of it is also to mask and and
kind of get masked the pain but also
break through the grave for the blue
like i like to say that grey hates
laughter
so there's a chapter in there
after some heavy stuff like in order to
go through the heavy stuff i gotta make
you laugh so we can go deal with it but
again there's a whole practical jokes
chapter of uh
this is the perils of being friends with
jay glazer and the crap that i pulled on
strahan and howie and
oh anybody and everybody you could
imagine even like the governor of
california i try to
i just met him one day
and um
i have this joke i play where if you
leave your phone in front of me i will
take your phone and then text someone
from your phone
usually a vile message and then erase
the sent text
so you have no idea you sent it so i've
had straight admit a lot of things to
people that are really awful like i have
no idea why he's still friends with me
except he has no other friends
and we meet him one day and strands
telling him what i do is i don't even
leave your phone in front of jay and the
dude leaves his phone right there like
two minutes later i'm like well it's his
fault the governor of california so i go
grab his first phone
go grab his phone and the last guy he
was texting was bill clinton i was like
oh this is great
and michael's like no i'm like shut up
it's straight it's like no shut up so i
start texting and then gavin turns
around oh my god jumps over and grabs it
i was like it's your fault we just told
you this you know and i wasn't able to
send it's not i wasn't able to get it oh
my god it would have been my yeah it
would have been a masterpiece but a
masterpiece
wow
but
i don't care and there's there's there's
stuff in there
i gotta tell this one
there's one night strahan and i are out
in new york city
and uh this waiter came over man this
waiter was just he was having a bad day
yeah but he was taking out on us
so it was bad though he was just being
so not cool to us so at the end i'm like
i'm gonna mess with this dude a little
bit and i pull out my um
blue my uh insurance card my health
insurance card which looked like a
credit card for whatever insurance i was
on back then and michael's like stop how
much
so i put it in the bill and the guy
comes over he goes over and he comes
back over he goes to run it he comes
back over he goes i know i'm wearing all
white but i'm not a doctor and i just
deadpan and i go
i don't get it
he's like you give me a health insurance
card i said yeah i know i'm covered here
i said uh listen i'm not going through
this again this is one of the
restaurants restaurants in my my network
i already met my deductible i'm not
going through this again please run it
again
and he's like because i just said it so
like seriously yeah and michael's like
kicking me under the table like please
make it stop i'm like nah forget this
guy so the guy could put if you just say
like i said yeah not listen i met my
deductible journey you know he's just so
he goes over starts running again and he
holds it up to the manager and the
manager looks at him looks at the card
looks at him and he's like
it's a health insurance card
and the guy comes back over i said no no
i know i know i said look you were just
such a
blanket blank to us i said i figure
you're having the worst dance and i'll
loosen you up a little bit he goes once
i realized that complete [ __ ] to us he
goes i'm sorry but you're right i was
having a horrible day but you're right
this did lift the upper like you see
that stray i'm a walking blessing there
you go
when stray was doing that april fool's
day gig
with with his teeth
did you know no did you know did you
know or did you were you like the rest
of us were like he couldn't really do
that like he he couldn't get rid of the
gap like that didn't he get you he did
it he well he did it and then
he went on vacation and realized that
like he tapped out crap like this
thing's kind of getting out of hand here
yeah
we were talking about it we thought it
was real right and we we had a whole
segment on the show saying you know
erlacker already left the brotherhood
behind he better not leave how do you
deal with that with her lacquer man no
no no because he left you behind
yeah but no i would stray i was like i
knew it wasn't real but
i was like i don't know how you're
getting out of this one now but he got
himself out of it
well he was such a big gag man people
were like i know i was okay to have a
gap because of you and now you stand
like oh my god i know
look out jump off the ship jump off the
ship
he turned it around he turned that ship
around no idea because he was on
vacation he turned his phone off jay
glazer here unbreakable how i turned my
depression and anxiety uh into
motivation and you can too where all
books are acquired uh sean payton who
you obviously know very well
you know
the grind of coaching man it's a serious
thing and again i don't know if anything
that you're talking about in this book
plays into what the grind of coaching
could be or because people are like okay
he left three years 45 million is long
you know and you could see he really
loved all the people he said goodbye to
because i think he just stopped talking
two seconds ago from his presidency i
think he's still going so
i said to him i said hey hey bro
your opening thing went up for an hour
and first of all you screwed this thing
up you want to do and we talked right
beforehand yeah and he's like i want to
do this ted lasso thing and i was like
yeah and just and then he comes on he's
like you know i love netflix and ted
lasso i said it's not even on netflix
bro it's an apple what are you doing
well it's his movies on his movies on
netflix so you know so now sean and i
man we we started talking about this
about three months ago
and he kept going back and forth back if
you watch me doing my during my coaching
carousel on you know week 18 of fox
interval sunday i said after
i think who's out i said and by the way
you'll probably have another opening or
so
from you know a coach that could step
away that um because it's been a tough
year or two with covid and that's what i
was talking about and
he was gonna he went into
originally we were gonna break it that
tuesday
right after
and i was like
visa but i want you know talk to mrs
benson when mrs benson told him hey juan
you take a few days off and and really
think about it so sean said you know i'm
not going to do it yet mrs benson wants
me to take a couple days off well a
couple days turned into two weeks of
cabo and then
when he came back it was better like hey
you this is your story this is your deal
you know however you want it to come out
which it should be if god says to me you
know at first he's like yeah you should
i'll let you i'll let you break it at
first but if he says you know what i
want to do this that's their prerogative
you know to do that um but we were
talking and and the thing too is i
didn't want to
go full in on it also because he did
kept changing his mind
like you might have said you know after
all that two weeks in cabo but i can
only imagine he
uh
just today just like as i said yesterday
just today he's not surprised to talk
about that i think i spoke to him this
morning he's have to worry about the
combine or what's going on at the senior
bowl this morning or last night either
one i was giving you know crap about his
one hour
yeah
a post handle an ambulance
i know so so he is you you think he is
definitely out for 2022 because you know
a lot of people think that he's just
trying to yeah another yeah but
even so if that's the case you know he's
not going to retire for three days and
get traded
to another team i don't think so no i
think he but
i think it's just hard for here's the
thing again mvp
it's a charity for transition yes so i
think he wants to step away but at the
same time there's probably a fear like
okay well i've never not been on a team
i've never not been part i mean this is
going back right right high school
college yeah nfl he's never not been in
a locker room so i think some of that
too
it kind of jolts you a little bit so
he's like oh okay well i think i could
do this but i'm not sure i could not be
around my locker room well every coach
i've ever worked with former coach i've
ever worked with on television still has
i mean you never get that
competition wanting to talk to the refs
even if you're you know on the sideline
or yeah of a broadcast you know like
they they
the
and and he even said he thinks he'll get
back into coaching at some point i mean
he also mentioned tv you mentioned a lot
of stuff he's always i mean i think he's
you know mentioned me you know a year or
two he said but i don't know they go on
loan i don't know i don't know how much
i'm going to love this or not love this
right
you know and i think too for a lot of
coaches
you know
the losses are so hard on them and their
families
and when it gets to the point where
you can't enjoy the wins anymore that's
when you got to kind of move it along no
question and all those guys here you
know jimmy johnson will tell you the
same thing and you know i haven't talked
to bill cower but i'm assuming they all
go through the same thing jamora senior
told me that the loss the the sting of
the losses and the depression of the
loss has
lasted so long and was so more more
intense than the excitement over the
wins but
that's when it's time to
exhale and take a breath
right and that's what happens to a lot
of these guys the losses beat them down
so much sometimes happen to mad happen
over meals you know enjoy the wins
anymore
so do you think that's what that's part
of it what happened with sean or again
it's
it's just been a lot over the over the
years right so this is something again
he started telling me about three months
ago and he was
pretty
he seemed at peace with it three months
ago
and then also and he kind of you know
three weeks later he'd have an idea and
then oh maybe if i so it
again or he'd be really excited about
something almost the place i
speaking of possible rule changes um do
you think there's anything to uh the
overtime the way that's
in city we've been in league for how
long i know this is my 30th year this is
how long you've been in this league this
is my 19th okay
i don't ever remember a year we don't
talk about it it's not brought up it's
right brooch that the owners being it's
always so this isn't something that all
of a sudden right now this is and they
it's always talked about and yeah i
don't think it's fair
i don't think it's i don't
having the the you know a coin top the
luck of a coin toss
that has nothing to do with your
preparation or your team
has nothing to do with that's not an
even playing field in my opinion so it
should be
i mean the obviously we're getting there
we're all if you only take a field goal
but i i think you should have a level
playing field yeah i but this is a
league as you know or been a light
change
boy
changes yeah well i mean i kind of like
the idea of getting rid of an onside
kick or you could still do it but you
can do one shot from your you know
thirty five on a little bit kicks i
don't wish i could like kicks were
easier i i i you know what i mean it
just
changes
to tell the officials like hey okay
about half thirty a game last football
question then we'll return to the book
and send you on your day sir um how do
you think roger's gonna play out what do
you think
i thought he was gonna
i was really like early in the week i
did interviews and and uh they said you
think aaron i said yeah i think he goes
on and now i flip-flop the other way
that he he stays
so again it's aaron rodgers so
i'm never gonna try and predict what
aaron is really
what's going on between his ears
um but i was
i thought he was gonna move on and now i
think if there a i'm more convinced that
i wouldn't be as surprised i guess if he
ends up staying and i would have been
three days ago
well you know the conversation today as
soon as you leave here i'm sure it's on
your phone all over the place too is the
hiring of nathaniel hackett in in denver
where again you know all
word out of there is he gets it on his
own merits he's his own man
yeah he crushed the interview okay which
is great but you know what helps is
rogers if that whole idea that the
broncos were interested in him on
draftking last year
maybe this would be attractive to aaron
to go in a different direction sure
absolutely
again that's
that's right there hitting a square in
the face but
i'm just just in the conversation that
you know the conversations that i have
i was a little more convinced
well again i would have been i said
three days ago i'd be surprised if he
was in green bay now i'm saying i
wouldn't be surprised if he's in green
bay but i'll probably go back and forth
on that as much as sean payton did so
yeah over the last few days the more i
talk to people the more i'm okay well
that's okay well and it's people who
know aaron so i get convinced both ways
all right last one for you is why do you
think it is so difficult
to share
what you're sharing in this book for so
many people because shame it's the shame
but who's the one making them feel
ashamed strand's been my best friend for
30 years right
it wasn't until two months ago and i
told him man we're supposed to do dinner
and i said i can't go out tonight he
said well i said
man the beast got out of the box man the
monster got me
and
you know when i when my i have attacks
it's um it's a physical visceral
reaction for me i feel it here behind my
rib cage in the left side of my gut and
my joints ache like i just had a 50
round fight it just exhausted me and it
hits you out of nowhere know where this
one woke me up in the middle of the
night and it just it's not always like
that this one was particularly bad is it
a dream or is it just like where
somebody says something and it sparks
something they wake up thinking my sky
is falling and don't know why okay i
could just fight back against it and
that's it like i'm never gonna let this
thing win right that's it i will never
top out against this i'll always fight
back against it um
and i told
straight can't go to dinner man i'm just
man just exhausted
the the the monster you know monster
kind of you know beat me down here today
and he said you want me to come over i
said no
you want to just talk about it i said no
he said i've been your best friend for
30 years
why have you never told me about this
the first time i ever talked to him
about it
30 years
i said
i don't know man i don't make up the
rules of this thing with you i felt
ashamed
maybe because
so competitive and that i don't know but
had i not felt shame
i would have had somebody for 30 years
who would was willing to come over was
willing to talk so that's why we got to
take the shame out of i'm saying this
story right here
you guys don't look at me any
differently you don't look at me any
weaker no right yeah so as much as like
i said
i'm trying to learn how to brag about my
mental scars and have all of us
brag about it to be a badge of honor and
i think we're so
like i said we've all been through this
pandemic and we've social media makes us
all think our lives suck
so everybody has some form of gray in
their lives and i think if we could bond
together as a team right now and walk
this walk together
we could be this thing beyond all the
way back into what's all where it
belongs to be
but it's a daily battle man it's
something i'll deal with for the rest of
my life
um
by having more teammates out there
which i'll have now from writing the
book yeah it'll give me the help i need
to so to say the first thing is to talk
about it now you've got this on the
mantle forever
and um because you know you
you you hear it all the time
that mental
health
or mental illness
is a sign of weakness
okay now do i seem weak
another person who sat in this chair
dude another person who sat in this
chair tyson fury yes
same thing
same conversation talking about the gray
or or his version of it
and
so
that's why it doesn't compute like i
hear it and i'm not thinking that
person's weakness i'm thinking that
person needs help you know when i see
antonio brown tell
bryant gumbel i don't have
you know i don't need mental help i have
mental wealth i think to myself
that's a sign that this person still
can't talk about it or something with
himself right and so i i that's that's
where i'm at and i'm wondering how we
get to more people to where i'm at you
know and even where
we're at yeah even where
the days are the periods that things are
going great for me i still have to
practice this just while we practice
anything else in sports anything else
you do in life yeah mental health you
got to practice it every single day of
your life and
we all gotta you know build each other
up right and and as one of our vets jc
glick says we we
lift as we climb right we got to lift
each other up and
yeah it's certainly not a sign of
weakness and listen i know
people at home go what's this dude have
to be sad about her this lie his life is
great he has
money and fame and fortune and my life
is great i get to sit here with you and
i mean don johnson's on the show
come on like my life is unbelievable
incredible
but between my ears sucks
and that's just
just
the fact of the matter right and it's
something that i've got to learn to deal
with and i've got to use to motivate me
to you know what man if i did not have
depression anxiety i would not be as
successful as i am it would not have
forced me to go out there and be
relentless with everything i want to go
get so man for the first time
um
maybe god blessed me with depression
well to use your phrase we've got your
back thank you you know and um and
everybody in the nfl community does as
well i mean everything that you've done
with merging vets and players and you
know the hall of fame now reaching out
to you to merge their brand with yours
and fox and this book and everything and
you know we love
i love you jay i mean unbreakable how i
turned my depression and anxiety into
motivation and you can too where all
books can be taken
see you next week thank you for the
super bowl as well see you this week
excellent we got we got you know
something yeah we got again this going
on this weekend yeah it's pretty cool
we'll be there we're doing our show from
uh so far oh
yeah right down here we're right across
the street from us like you should yeah
should we have some sort of like
anchorman moment like
me and much
i don't know we've got 14 people on the
show like literally i think we're good
me straight i'll take me straight and
howie versus you guys okay yeah
we got bradshaw on the show first up
tomorrow i could start something let's
start something i could start something
we got his back
i know that if you're involved though
jay i will just stay put in my studio
what am i what am i even mentioning what
the hell am i talking about
check it out uh unbreakable how i turn
my depression anxiety and motivation
into motivation and you can too where
all books are required jay glazer here